hi there i'm samuel
and i'm here to walk you through some of
the aws interview questions
which we find are important and our hope
is that you would use this material
in your interview preparation and be
able to crack
that cloud interview and step into your
dream
cloud job by the way i'm and cloud
technical architect trainer
and an interview panelist for cloud
network
and devops so as you progress in
watching you're gonna see that these
questions are
practical scenario based questions that
tests the depth of the knowledge of a
person
in a particular aws product or in a
particular aws architecture
so why wait let's move on all right so
in an interview
you would find yourself with a question
that might ask you
define and explain the three basic types
of cloud services
and the aws products that are built
based on them
see here it's a very straightforward
question just explain
three basic types of cloud service
and when we talk about basic type of
cloud service
it's compute obviously that's a very
basic service
storage obviously because you need to
store your data somewhere
and networking that actually connects a
couple of other services
to your application these basic will not
include monitoring
these basic will not include analytics
because they are considered as optional
they are considered as advanced
services you could choose a non-cloud
service or a product for
monitoring of and for analytics so
they're not considered as basic so when
we talk about basics they are
compute storage and networking
and the second part of the questions is
explain some of the
aws products that are built based on
them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's
that's the major share of the compute
resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock
and then function as a service which is
lambda auto scaling and light cell
are also part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run
any application and the compute service
helps us
in managing the scaling and deployment
of an application again lambda is a
compute server so the compute service
also helps in
running event initiated stateless
applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis
is on storage these days because if
there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have
new data to store process manage so
storage is again a basic and an
important cloud service and the products
that
are built based on the storage services
are
s3 object storage glacier for archiving
ebs elastic block storage as a
drive attachment for the ec2 instances
and the efs
file share for the ec2 instances so the
storage domain helps in
the following aspects it holds all the
information that the application
uses so it's the application data and
we can also archive old data using
storage which would be glacier
and any object files and any requirement
for
block storage can be met through elastic
block store
and s3 which is again an object storage
talking about networks it's just not
important
to answer the question with the name of
the services and the name of the product
it'll also be good if you could go in
depth
and explain how they can be used
right so that actually proves you to be
a person
knowledgeable enough in that particular
service or product so
talking about networking domain vpc
networking can't imagine networking
without vpc
in in the cloud environment especially
in aws cloud environment
and then we have route 53 for domain
resolution
or for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an
edge caching service that helps
customers get
our customers to read their application
with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following
use cases it controls and manages the
connectivity
of the aws services within our account
and we can also pick an ip address
range if you're a network engineer or
if you are somebody who works in
networks or planning to work a network
you will soon realize the importance of
choosing your own ip address for easy
remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud
owned range of ip address in the cloud
it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that get asked would
be
the difference between the availability
zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked so to test
how well you can actually differentiate
and also correlate the availability zone
and the region relationship right so
a region is a separate geographic area
like the us2s1 i mean which represents
uh north california or the ap south
which
represents mumbai so regions are a
separate
geographic area on the contrary
availability zone
resides inside the region you shouldn't
stop there you should go further and
explain about availability zones and
availability zones are
isolated from each other and some of the
services will replicate themselves
within
the availability zone so availability
zone does replication within them but
regions they don't generally do
replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is
what is auto scaling what do we achieve
by
auto scaling so in short auto scaling it
helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances
whenever there is an demand it not only
helps us
meeting the increasing demand it also
helps in
reducing the resource usage when there
is
low demand so auto scaling also allows
us to decrease
the resources or resource capacity as
per the need of that particular r
now this helps business in not worrying
about
putting more effort in managing or
continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because auto
scaling
is going to handle it for us so business
does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially an
aws service the ability to increase and
shrink
based on the need of that r that's how
powerful is auto scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's due
targeting in cloud front now we know
that cloudfront is caching and it caches
content globally
in the amazon caching service global
wide the whole point
is to provide users worldwide
access to the data from a very nearest
server possible that's the whole point
in using or going for cloud front
then what do you mean by geo targeting
geotargeting is
showing customer and specific content
based on language we can customize the
content
based on what's popular in that place we
can actually customize the content the
url is the same
but we could actually change the content
a little bit
not the whole content otherwise it would
be dynamic but we can change
the content a little bit a specific a
file or a picture or a particular link
in a website and show customized content
to users
who will be in different parts of the
globe so how does it happen
cloudfront will detect the country where
the viewers
are located and it will forward the
country code to the origin
server and once the origin server gets
the specialized
or specific country code it will change
the content
and it will send to the caching server
and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country
they are in the other question you could
get asked is
the steps involved in using cloud
formation or creating a cloud formation
or
backing up an environment within cloud
formation template we all know that if
there is a template
we can simply run it and it provisions
the
environment but there is a lot more
going into it so the first step in
moving towards infrastructure as a code
is
to create the cloud formation template
which as of now
supports json and yaml file format
so first create the cloud formation
template and then
save the code in an x3 bucket history
bucket serves as
the repository for our code and then
from the cloud formation
call the file in the s3 bucket and
create a stack
and now cloud formation uses
the file reads the file understands
services that are being called
understands the order understands how
they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service
it understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship
between the different services and it
would set an order for itself
and then would provision the services
one after the other let's say
a service has a dependency and the
dependent service
the other service which this service
let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision
resource b what happens if we inverse
the order if we inverse the order
resource b first gets provision and
because it does not have dependency
changes that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly
something is not healthy it could roll
back chances that
the environment provisioning will roll
back so
to avoid that cloud formation first
provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent
on that's depended by another service
so it provisions those service first and
then provisions the services
that has dependencies and if you're
being
hired for a devops or you know if the
interviewer wanted to test your skill
on systems side this definitely
would be a question in his list how do
you upgrade or downgrade a system with
near zero downtime now everybody's
moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them
want their application to be highly
available so the question would be how
do you
actually upgrade or downgrade a system
with near zero downtime now we all know
that
i can upgrade an ec2 instance to a
better ec2 instance by changing
the instance type stopping and starting
but stopping and starting
is gonna cause a downtime right
so that's you should be answering or you
shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime
so upgrading system with zero downtime
it includes
launching another system parallelly with
the bigger
ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity
and install all that's needed if you're
going to use an ami of the old machine
well and good you don't have to go
through installing all the updates and
installing all the application
from the ami once you've launched it in
a bigger instance
locally test the application to see if
it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working
and if the application works we can
actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind a route 53 let's say all that
you could do is go to rot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of
the new server and that's going to send
traffic to the new server now
so the cutover is handled or if you're
using static ip
you can actually remove the static ip
from the old machine and assign it to
the new machine that's one way of doing
it
or if you are using elastic nic card you
can actually
remove the new card from the old machine
and attach the new card to the
new machine so that way we would get
near zero
downtime if you are hired for an
architect
level you should be worrying about cost
as well
along with the technology and this
question would test
how well you manage cost so what are the
tools and techniques we can use in aws
to identify and correct identify and
know that
we are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your aws resources running one way is to
check the billing there is a place where
you can check the
top services that were utilized it could
be free
and it could be paid service as well top
services that can be utilized it's
actually in the
dashboard of the cost management console
so that
table here shows the top five
most used services so looking at it you
can get it all right so i'm using a lot
of storage i'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that
and you will find if you are storing
things that
should be storing and then clean it up
why is compute capacity so high
why is data transfer so high so if you
start thinking in those levels you'll be
able to dig in
and clean up unnecessary and be able to
save
your bill and there are cost explorer
services available which will help you
to view
your usage pattern or view your spending
for the
past 13 months or so and it will also
forecast for the next three months now
how
much will you be using if your pattern
is like this
that will actually help and will give
you a visibility
on how much you have spent how much you
will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are
another excellent a way to control cost
you can actually set up budget alright
this is how much
i am willing to spend for this
application for this team or
for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget
mark and anytime it exceeds any
it's nearing you would get an alarm
saying that well we're about to
reach the allocated budget amount stuff
like that
that way you can go back and know and
you know that how much
the bill is going to be for that month
or you can take steps to control
bill amount for that particular month so
aws budget
is another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags
helps in identifying which team or which
resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of
looking at the bill as one list with no
specifications into it and looking at it
as an expenditure list you can actually
break it down
and tag the expenditure to the teams
with cost allocation
tax the dev team has spent so much the
production team has spent so much the
training team has spent
more than the dev and the production
team why is that
now you'll be able to you know think in
those levels only if you have cost
allocation tax
now cost allocation tags are nothing but
the tags that you would put when you
create a resource so for production
services you would put as a production
tag you would
create a production tag and you would
associate that resources to it and
at a later point when you actually pull
up your bill that's going to show a
detailed
a list of this is the owner this is the
group
and this is how much they have used in
the last month
and you can move forward with your
investigation and encourage or
stop users using more services with the
cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or
is there any other way of accessing aws
resource
other than the console console is gui
right
so in other words other than gui how
would you use the aws resource and how
familiar are you with those
tools and technologies the other tools
that are available
that we can leverage and access the aws
resource are
of course footy you can configure putty
to access the aws
resources like log into an ec2 instance
and ec2 instance does not always have to
be logged in
through the console you could use putty
to log into an ec2 instance
like the jump box like the proxy machine
and
like the gateway machine and from there
you can
actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an
alternative to the console and of course
we have the
aws cli in any of the linux machines
or windows machines we can install so
that's
point two three and four we can install
aws cli
for linux windows also for mac so we can
install them
and from there from your local machine
we can access
run aws commands and access provision
monitor
the aws resources the other ones are we
can access the
aws resource programmatically using aws
sdk
and eclipse so these are a bunch of
options we have to use the aws resource
other than the console if you're
interviewed in a company or
by a company that focuses more on
security and
want to use aws native services for
their security then
you would come across this question what
services can be used to create a
centralized
logging solution the basic services we
could use our cloud watch logs
store them in s3 and then use
elasticsearch
to visualize them and use kinesis to
move the data from
s3 to elasticsearch right so log
management it actually helps
organizations to track the relationship
between
operational and security changes and the
events that got triggered
based on those logs instead of logging
into an instance or instead of
logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically
i can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs
every time there's a change the system
will scream and it gets tracked
in the cloud watch and then cloud watch
pushes it to s3
kinesis pushes the data from s3 to
elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an
a fair understanding of what was going
on in the environment for the past
one or whatever the time window that i
wanted to look at
so it helps in getting a good
understanding of the infrastructure as a
whole
all the logs are getting saved in one
place so all the infrastructure logs
are getting saved in one place so it's
easy for me to look at it in an
infrastructure perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect
to each other it could be logs that
belongs to
a one account it could be logs that
belongs to multiple accounts
it doesn't matter you know those three
services are gonna work fairly good
and they're gonna inject or they're
gonna like
suck logs from the other accounts put it
in one place and help us to monitor so
as you see you have cloud watch here
that actually tracks the metrics you can
also use cloud
trail if you want to log api calls as
well
push them in an s3 bucket so there are
different types of blog
flow logs are getting captured in an
instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account
from a different account and all of them
are analyzed using elasticsearch
using the kibana client so step one is
to
deploy the ecs cluster step two is to
restrict access to the ecs cluster
because it's valid data
you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so
resting access to the ecs dashboard and
we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloudwatch to the elasticsearch
domain and then kibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize
the logs instead of looking at log as
just statements or
in a bunch of characters a bunch of
files kibana helps us to analyze
the logs in a graphical or a chart or a
bar diagram
format again in an interview the
interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on aw security products
especially on the logging monitoring
even management or incident management
then you could have a question like this
what are the native aws
security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging
in them like have their own logging like
s3 s3 has its own login
and cloudfront has its own login ds has
its own login vpc has its own login
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail
and aws config services so there are
variety of
logging options available in the aws
like cloud trail
config cloudfront redshift logging rds
logging vpc flow logs
s3 object logging s3 access logging
stuff like that so we're going to look
at two servers in specific cloud trail
now this cloud trail the very first
product in that picture we just thought
the cloud trail provides an very high
level
history of the api calls for all the
account
and with that we can actually perform a
very good security analysis
a security analysis of our account and
these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to s3 for
long time archivals and based on a
particular event it can also
send an email notification to us saying
hey just got this error
thought i'll let you know stuff like
that the other one is config service
a config service helps us to understand
the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also
set up notifications based on the
configuration changes
so it records the cumulative changes
that are
made in a short period of time so if you
want to go through
the lifetime of a particular resource
what are the things that happened
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using
aws config all right the other question
you could get
asked is if you know your role includes
taking care of cloud security as well
then the other question you could get
asked is the native services that amazon
provides
or to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service
now not all companies would go with
amazon native
services but there are some companies
which
want to stick with amazon native
services just to
save them from the headache of managing
the other softwares or
bringing in another tool a third-party
tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary
amazon native services and a lot of
companies
are using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service
now denial of service is if you already
know what denial of service is well and
good if you do not know then
let's know it now denial of service is a
user trying to or maliciously making
attempt
to access a website or an application
the user would actually create multiple
sessions and
he would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let
legitimate users access the servers so
he's in turn denying the service for the
user a quick
picture review of what denial of
services
now look at it these users instead of
making one connection they are making
multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available
that would actually trigger connections
from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so
everything kind of looks legitimate for
the server and it would accept those
connections
and it would keep the sessions open the
actual users won't be able to use them
so that's denying
the service for the actual users denial
of service
all right and distributed denial of
service is uh generating attacks from
multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's
distributed denial of service so the
tools the native tools that helps us
to prevent the denial of service attacks
in aws
is cloud shield and web access
firewall aws now they are the major ones
they are designed
to mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by
denial of service then we should be
using aws shield
or aws vaf and there are a couple of
other tools that
also does when i say that also does
denial of service is not their primary
job
but you could use them for denial of
service
route 53's purpose is to provide dns
cloudfront is to provide caching elastic
load balancer
elbs work is to provide load balancing
vpc is to create and
secure a virtual private environment but
they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent
you would get in aws shield and aws web
so aws shield and waff are the primary
ones
but the rest can also be used to
mitigate
distributed denial of service the other
tricky question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region
so when you're trying to provision a
service in a particular region
you're not seeing the service in that
region how do we go about
fixing it or how do we go about using
the service in the cloud
it's a tricky question and if you have
not gone through such situation
you can totally blow it away you really
need to have a good understanding on
regions the services available in those
regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it
the answer is not all services are
available in
all regions anytime amazon announces a
new service they don't
immediately publish them on all regions
they start small
and as in when the traffic increases as
and when it becomes more likeable to the
customers
they actually move the service to
different regions
so as you see in this picture within
america north virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california
so within not america itself north
virginia is the preferred one
so similarly there are preferred regions
within
europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime
we don't see a service in a particular
region chances that the service is not
available in that region yet we got to
check the documentation and find the
nearest
region that offers that service and
start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it
you could but you know that's going to
add more latency
to your application so that's why we
need to check for application which is
check for region which is very near
to the place where you want to serve
your customers and find
nearest region instead of always going
back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again a laser place
there's a link in aws.com that
you can go and look for services
available in
different region and that's exactly what
you're seeing here
and if your service is not available in
a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest
other region that provides that service
and start using service from there
with the coming up of cloud a lot of
companies have turned down their
monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups
and new companies that are thinking of
having a monitoring environment
that they don't want to go with
traditional knock monitoring instead
they would like to leverage
aws monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff
not just the availability but it
monitors a lot of stuff like
failures errors it also triggers
emails stuff like that so how do you
actually set up a monitor
to website how to set up a monitor to
monitor
the website metrics in real time in aws
the simple way anytime you have a
question about
monitoring cloud watch should strike
your mind
because cloud watch is meant for
monitoring
is meant for collecting metrics is meant
for
providing graphical representation of
what's going on
in a particular network at a particular
point of time
so cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications
and using cloudwatch we can monitor the
state changes
not only the state changes the auto
scaling life cycle
events anytime there are there are more
services added there is a reduction in
the number of servers because of less
usage
and very informative messages can be
received through cloudwatch
any cloudwatch can now support scheduled
events
if you want to schedule anything
cloudwatch has an event
that would schedule an action all right
schedule a trigger
time based not incident based you know
anything happening and then
you get an action happening that's
incident based
on the other hand you can simply
schedule few things on time based so
that's possible with cloud watch
so this cloud watch integrates very well
with a lot of other services like
notifications for notifying the user
or for notifying the administrator about
it and it can integrate
well with lambda so to trigger an action
anytime you're
designing an auto healing environment
this cloud watch can actually
monitor and send an email if we are
integrating it with
sns simple notification service or this
cloud watch can
monitor and based on what's happening it
can trigger an
event in lambda and that would in turn
run a function
till the environment comes back to
normal so
cloudwatch integrates well with a lot of
other aw services
all right so cloudwatch has uh three
statuses
green when everything is going good
yellow
when the service is degraded and red
when the service is not available
green is good so we don't have to do
anything about it but anytime there is
an ello
the picture that we're looking at it's
actually calling
and lambda function to debug the
application
and to fix it and anytime there's a red
alert it immediately notifies
the owner of the application about well
the service is down
and here is the report that i have here
is the metrics that i've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role
requires you to manage the servers as
well
there are certain job roles which are on
the system side
there are certain job roles which is
development plus
system side now you're responsible for
the application and the server as well
so if that's the case you might be
tested with some basic questions like
the different types of virtualization in
aws and what are the difference between
them
all right the three major types of
virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization
on hardware virtual module all right the
difference between them or actually
describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
hardware you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other
and these vms are booted by executing
master
boot record in the root block and when
we talk about
para virtualization paragraph is
actually the special
boot loader which boots the pv amis
and when we talk about pv on hvm it's
it's actually the marriage between hvm
and
pv and this para virtualization
on hvm in other words pv on hvm
it actually helps operating system take
advantage
in storage and the network input
output available through the host
another good question is
name some of the services that are not
region specific
now you've been thought that all
services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability zone
ebs is within an availability zone s3 is
region specific
dynamodb is region specific stuff like
that
vpc is both availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and
vpcs region specific stuff like that so
you might have thought you might have
learned in that combination
but there could be some tricky questions
that tests you how well you have
understood the region
non-region and availability
non-availability
services i should say there are services
that are not
region specific that would be iam
so we can't have im for every
availability zone
and for every region which means you
know users will have to
use one username and password for one
region and anytime they switch
to another region they will have to use
another username and password that
that's more work and that's not a good
design as well
authentication has to be global so im is
a global service
and which means it's not region specific
on the other hand
route 53 is again a regional specific so
we can't have
a route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region
specific service it's a global service
and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each
region if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall
works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region
based service so the web application
firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service
though you can you know cache content on
a continent
and country basis it's still considered
a global service
right it's not bound to any region so
when you activate cloud front
you're activating it away from region or
availability zone so when you're
activating
a web application firewall because it's
not a region-specific service you're
activating it
away from availability zone and regions
so a quick recap i am users groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used
globally and all 53 services are offered
at edge locations and they are global as
well
web application firewall a service that
protects our web application from
common web exploits they are global
service as well
cloudfront cloudfront is global content
delivery network
cdn and they are offered at edge
locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific
service or beyond region service
all right this is another good question
as well in the project that you are
being interviewed if they really want to
secure
their environment using nat or if they
are already securing their environment
using nat
by any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances
you can expect this question what are
the difference between
an ad gateway and that instances now
they both
saw the same thing right so they're not
two different
services trying to achieve two different
things they both
serve the same thing but still they do
have
differences in them right on a high
level they both achieve providing
netting for the service behind it but
the difference comes
when we talk about the availability of
it
that gateway is a managed service by
amazon whereas nat
instance is managed by us now i'm
talking about the third point
maintenance here nat gateway is managed
by amazon
that instance is managed by us and
availability of nat
gateway is very high and availability of
that
instance is less compared to
the nat gateway because it's managed by
us
you know it's on an ec2 instance which
could
actually fail and if it fails we'll have
to relaunch it but if it is not
gateway if something happens to that
service amazon would take care of
reprovisioning it and talking about
bandwidth it can
burst up to 75 gigabits now traffic
through the net gateway can burst up to
75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and
if we are launching a t2 micro it barely
gets any bandwidth
so there's a difference there and the
performance because
it's highly available because of the
bigger pipe 75 gigabits
now the performance of the nat gateway
is very high but the performance of the
nat
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of
the net instance that we pick and
billing
a billing for nat gateway is the number
of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the nat gateway
but billing for that instance is number
of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration
and the type of instance that we use
security in that gateway cannot be uh
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance
security is a bit customizable i can go
and change the security because it's a
server managed by
me or managed by us i can always change
the security well allow this allow
don't allow this stuff like that size
and load of the night gateway
is uniform but the size and the load of
the that instance changes as per an ad
gateway is a fixed product
but not instance can be small instance
can be a big instance so
the size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have
your instance stopped and where you have
your instance terminated
if you have only used lab and are
attending the interview chances
are that you might you always lost when
answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same
but there is a difference in it so when
you stop an
instance it actually performs a normal
shutdown
on the instance and it simply moves the
instance to the
stopped state but when you actually
terminate the instance
the instance is moved to this stop state
the
evs volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and we'll never be
able to recover them again so that's
a big difference between stopping and
terminating
an instance if you're thinking of using
the instance again along with the data
in it you should only be thinking of
stopping the instance but you should be
terminating the instance only if you
want to get rid of that
instance forever if you are being
interviewed for an architect level
position or a junior architect level
position or even a
cloud consultant level position or even
in an engineering
position this is a very common question
that gets
asked what are the different types of
easy to instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them all right they're all computer
capacity
for example the different types are on
demand instances
spot instances and reserved instances it
kind of
looks the same they all provide the
compute capacity they all provide the
same
type of hardwares for us but if you are
looking at
cost saving or optimizing cost in our
environment we got to be very careful
about which one are we picking now we
might think that well i'll go with
on-demand instance because i pay
on a per hour basis which is cheap you
know i can use them
anytime i want and anytime i don't want
i can simply get rid of it by
terminating it
you're right but if the requirement is
to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances
you'll be wasting a lot of money paying
on an hourly basis
instead we should be going for reserved
instance
where we can reserve the capacity for
the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount
in buying reserved instances all right
so under man is cheap to start with
if you're only planning to use it for a
short while but if you're planning to
run
it for a long while then we should be
going for reserved instance
that is what is cost efficient so spot
instance
is cheaper than on-demand instance and
there are different use cases for spot
instance as well so let's look at one
after the other
the on-demand instance the on-demand
instance is purchased at a fixed rate
per r this is very short-term and
irregular
workloads and for testing for
development
on-demand instance is a very good use
case we should be using on demand
for production spot instance spot
instance
allows users to purchase ec2 at a
reduced price
and anytime we have more instances we
can always go and
sell it in spot instances i'm referring
to anytime we have more reserved
instances
we can always sell them in spot instance
catalog and the way we buy spot instance
is we actually put a budget this is how
much i'm willing to pay
all right would you be able to give
service within this cost so anytime the
price
comes down and meets the cost that we
have put in
will be assigned an instance and any
time the price shoots up the instance
will be taken away from us
but in case of on-demand instances we
have bought that instance for that
particular r and it stays with us but
with spot instances
it varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price
goes away to somebody else and the spot
instance availability is actually based
on
supply and demand in the market there's
no guarantee that you will get spot
instance at all time
all right so that's a caveat there you
should be familiar with
that's a caveat that you should be aware
when you are proposing somebody that we
can go for spot instance and save money
it's not always going to be available if
you want your spot instance to be
available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this
month so how can i code or how much can
i code stuff like that
so you got to look at those history
before you propose somebody that
well we're going to save money using
spot instance on the other hand
reserved instance provide cost savings
for
the company we can opt for reserved
instances
for you know one year or three years
there are actually three types of
reserved instances
light medium and heavy reserved
instances
they are based on the amount that we
would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on
are we doing all upfront or no upfront
or
partial payment then split the rest as
monthly payments so there are many
purchase options available but overall
if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years
you should not be going for on-demand
instance you should be going for
reserved instance and that's what gives
you the cost
benefit and in an error-based interview
sometimes you might be asked
you know how you interact with the aws
environment are you using cli
are you using console and depending on
your answer whether console or a cli
the panelist put a score okay this
person is cli specific this person is
console specific or
this person has used aws environment
through the sdk
stuff like that so this question tests
whether you are a cli person
or an console person and the question
goes like this
how do you set up ssh agent forwarding
so that you do not have to copy the key
every time you log in if you have used
puri
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have
to put the ip and the port number along
with that you will have to map
or we will have to map the key in the
puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments
right but in production environment
using the same key or mapping the same
key again and again
every time it's actually an hassle it's
considered as a blocker
so you might want to cache it you might
want to permanently add it
in your putty session so you can
immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a
quick button that actually fixes or that
actually
binds your ssh to your putty instance so
we can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key
to the ssh and next time when we try to
log in
you don't have to always go through
mapping the key and trying to log in
all right this question what are solares
and ax operating systems are they
available with aws
that question generally gets asked to
test how
familiar are you with the amis available
how familiar are you with ec2 how
familiar are you with the ec2 hardwares
available that basically test that now
the first question
or the first thought that comes to your
mind is well everything is available
with
aws i've seen windows i've seen ubuntu
i've seen red hat i've seen
amazon amis and if i don't see my
operating system there i can always go
to marketplace and
try them if i don't find a marketplace i
can always go to community and try them
so a lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available
i will be able to find solaris and ax
but that's not the case
solar s and ax are not available with
aws
that's because solaris uses a different
and solaris does not support the
architecture does not support
public cloud currently the same goes for
ax
as well they run on power cpu and not on
intel
and as of now amazon does not provide
power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a
high performance computing should not be
confused with that now these are
different hardwares different cpu itself
that the cloud providers they
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in
organizations that would want to
automate their infrastructure
using amazon native services would be
how do you actually recover
an ec2 instance or auto recover an ec2
instance
when it fails well we know that ec2
instances
are considered as immutable meaning
irreparable
we don't spend time fixing bugs in an os
stuff like that you know once an ec2
instance crashes like
it goes on a always panic or there are
various reasons why it would
fail so we don't have to really worry
about fixing it we can always
relaunch that instance and that would
fix it but
what if it happens at two o'clock in the
night what if it happens that
during the weekend when nobody's in
office looking or monitoring those
instances so you would want to automate
that
not only on a weekend or during midnight
but
it's general practice good to automate
it so you could
face this question how do you actually
automate an ec2 instance once it fails
and the answer to that question is using
cloudwatch we can recover the instance
so as you see
there is an alarm threshold a set in
cloudwatch
and once the threshold is met meaning if
there is an error if there is a failure
if the ec2 instance is not responding
for a certain while we can set an alarm
and once the alarm is met let's say the
cpu utilization
stayed high for five minutes all right
it's not taking any
new connections or the instance is not
pinging
for five minutes or in this case it's
two minutes
it's not pinging so it's not going to
respond connection so in those cases you
would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by
rebooting the instance all right now
look at this
the take this action section under the
action so
there we have a bunch of options like
recover this instance meaning
reboot the instance so that's how we
would recover the other two options are
beyond the scope of the question
but still you can go ahead and apply
just like i'm going to do it
so the other option is stop the instance
that's very useful
when you want to stop instances that are
having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running
and wasting the cloud expenditure so you
can actually set an alarm
that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and
they left it without or they forgot to
shut down that instance and
it gets i mean they will only use it
again the next day morning so in between
there could be like
12 hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it
so you can identify such instances and
actually stop them
when the cpu utilization is low meaning
nobody is using it
the other one is to terminate let's say
you want to give
system to somebody temporarily and you
don't want them to hand the system back
to you
all right this is actually an idea in
other words this is actually the
scenario so you hand over a system to
somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system
so you could instruct the other person
to terminate the system when they're
done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever
or you can monitor the system after the
specified time is over and you can
terminate the system or
best part you can automate the system
termination so you assign a system to
somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning
they've already left or cpu is low for
30 minutes meaning they've already left
stuff like that so that's possible and
if you're getting hired for an
system side architect or even on the
sysop site
you could face this question what are
the common and different types of ami
designs
there are a lot of ami designs the
question is the common ones
and the difference between them so the
common ones are the full back
a mice and the other one is just enough
os ami j e os ami
and the other one is hybrid type amis
so let's look at the difference between
them the full backed ami
just like the name says it's fully baked
it's
ready to use ami and this is the
simplest ami to deploy
can be a bit expensive it can be a bit
cumbersome because
you'll have to do a lot of work
beforehand you could
use the ami so a lot of planning a lot
of thought process will go into
it and the ami is ready to use right you
hand over the ami to somebody and
it's ready to use or if you want to
reuse the ami it's already ready for you
to use so that's
full baked ami the other one is just
enough operating system ami just like
the name says
it has i mean as you can also see in the
diagram
or in the picture it covers a part
of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging
and the other stuff are configured at
the time of deployment or at the time
you would be using it
so not much thought process will go in
here the only focus is on
choosing the operating system and what
goes the operating system specific
agents or bootstraps that goes into the
operating system that's all
we worry about the advantage of this is
it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time
of deploying but that's going to require
an additional
expertise on the person who will be
using the ami so that's
another overhead there but the advantage
is that it's kind of
flexible i can change the configurations
during the time of
deployment the other one is the hybrid
ami
now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between the fully baked ami
and just enough operating system options
so these amis have some features of the
big type and some features of the just
enough os type
so as you see the security monitoring
logging are
packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed
during the time of a deployment so this
is where the strict company policies
would go into the ami company policies
like you gotta log this
you gotta monitor this these are the
ports that generally gets open in all
the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an ami format and during
deployment
you have the flexibility of choosing the
different runtime and the application
that sits in an
ec2 instance another very famous
question you would face in an interview
is
how can you recover login to an ec2
instance to which
you lost the key well we know that if
the key is lost
we can't recover it there are some
organizations that integrate their ec2
instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the ad and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific
tricky question is you are using a key
to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key
generally companies would have made a
backup of the key so we can pick from
the backup but
here the specific question is we have
lost the key literally no backups on the
key at all so how can we log in and we
know that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover
is that make the instance use another
key and use
that key to log in once the key is lost
it's lost forever we won't be able to
recover it you can't raise the ticket
with amazon not possible
they're not going to help it's beyond
the scope so make the instance
use another key it's only the key that's
the problem
you still have valid data in it you got
to recover the data it's just the key
that's having the problem
so we can actually focus on the key part
alone and change the key
and that will allow us to log in so how
do we do it
step by step procedure so first verify
the ec2 config service is running in
that instance
if you want you can actually beforehand
install
the easy to config in that service or
you can actually make the easy to config
run through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run
in that ec2 instance and then detach the
root volume for that instance of course
it's going to require a stop and start
to detach the root volume from the
instance attach the root volume
to another instance as a temporary
volume or it could be a temporary
instance that you've launched only to
fix this issue
and then log in to that instance and to
that
particular volume and modify the
configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key
and then move the root volume back to
its original position and restart
the instance and now the instance is
going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can
log in so that's how we go ahead and fix
it
now let's move on to some product
specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably
and the interviewer would want to test
your knowledge on
s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences
between aws s3 and ebs well the
differences are
s3 is an object store meaning you can't
install anything in it you can store
drive files but you can't actually
install in it it's not a file system
but ebs is a file system you can install
services i mean install applications in
it and that's going to run
stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is
much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because
from the instance if you need to access
s3 you'll actually have to go out
through the internet and access the s3
or
s3 is an external service very external
service you'll have to go through
or you'll have to go outside of your vpc
to access s3
s3 does not come under a vpc but ebs
comes under a vpc
it's on the same vpc so you would be
able to use
it kind of locally compared to s3 ebs is
very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy
talking about redundancy of s3 and ebs
s3
is replicated the data in s3 is
replicated across
the data centers but ebs is replicated
within the data center meaning
s3 is replicated across availability
zones
ebs is within an availability zone so
that way the redundancy is
a bit less in ebs in other words
redundancy is higher in s3
than eps and talking about security of
s3 is3 can be made private as well as
public meaning anybody can access s3
from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but
ebs can only only be accessed when
attached to an ec2 instance
right just one instance can access it
whereas s3 is publicly directly
accessible
the other question related to s3
security is how do you allow access to a
user
to a siren a user to a certain bucket
which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all
but this user needs to be given access
to a certain bucket how do we do it
the same case applies to servers as well
in few cases
there could be an instance where a
person is new to the team and
you actually don't want them to access
the production service
now he's in the production group and by
default he or she is granted access to
that server but you specifically want to
deny access to that production server
till the time
he or she is matured enough to access or
understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances
and we would actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize
right so you put a tag on them put a tag
saying well they are highly critical
they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production
stuff like that and then you would pick
the users
who wants to or who should be or should
not be given access to a certain
server and you would actually allow the
user
to access or not access servers based on
a specific tag in other words
you can use actually tags in in the
previous step we put tags on the
critical server right so you would
define that this user is not going to
use this tag
right this user is not allowed to use
the resources with this stack so that's
how you would
make your step forward so you would
allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case
he or she will not be allowed to servers
which are
tagged critical servers so that's how
you allow deny access
to them and the same goes for bucket as
well
if an organization is excessively using
s3 for their data storage because of
the benefit that it provides the cost
and the
durability you might get asked this
question
which is organizations would replicate
the data from
one region to another region for
additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy
not only for that they would also do
that for dr purposes
for disaster recovery if the whole
region is down you still have the data
available somewhere else and you can
pick and use it
some organizations would store data in
different regions
for compliance reasons to provide low
latency access to their
users who are local to that region stuff
like that
so when companies do replication how do
you make sure that there is consistency
in the replication how do you make sure
that the replication is not failing
and the data gets transferred for sure
and there are logs
for that replication this is something
that the companies would use
where they're excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on
the replication in running their
business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region
level replication is happening properly
so this is how
it happens now on this side on the left
hand side we have the region 1
and on the right hand side we have
region 2 and region 1 is the source
bucket and region 2 is the
destination bucket right so object is
put in the source bucket
and it has to go directly to the region
to bucket or
or made a copy in the region to bucket
and the problem is sometimes it fails
and
there is no consistency between them so
the way you would do it is
connect these services together and
create and cross replication
or cross region replication monitor that
actually monitors
that actually monitors your environment
so there are cloud watch that make sure
that
the data is uh moved no data is failing
again there's cloud watch on the other
end make sure that the data is
moving and then we have the logs
generated
through cloudtrail and that's actually
written
in dynamodb and if there is an error if
something is failing
you get notified through an sms or you
get notified through an
email using the sns service so that's
how we could
leverage these tools and set up and
cross region replication
monitor that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc
is that we all know that i can use route
53
to resolve an ip address externally from
the internet
but by default the servers won't connect
to the other servers
using our custom dns name that does not
do that
by default so it's actually a problem
there are some additional things that
as an administrator or as an architect
or as a person who uses it
you will have to do and that's what
we're going to discuss so
the question could be vpc is not
resolving
the server through the dns you can
access it through the ip but not through
the
dns name and what could be the issue and
how do you go about
fixing it and you will be able to answer
this question only if you have
done it already it's a quick and simple
step by default vpc does not allow
that's the default feature and we will
have to enable
the dns hostname resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns
that comes along this is for the custom
dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution
so our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution
so they actually resolve let's say i
want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to server
one simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and
they have a head office in a central
place and the rest of them are branch
offices
and they are connecting to the head
office for
access or you know for saving data or
for accessing certain files or certain
data or storing data
all right so they would actually mimic
the hub and
spoke topology where you have the vpc
which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then
you would have a local vpcs or branch
offices
in different other regions and they get
connected to the
vpc in the central location and the
question is how do you actually
connect the multiple sites to a vpc and
make
communication happen between them by
default
it does not do that we know that vpcs
they need to be
paired between them in order to access
the resources
let's look at this picture right so i
have like a customer
network or branch offices in different
parts
and they get connected to a vpc that's
fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices the remote
offices
they are connecting to the vpc and
they're talking but they can't
connect or they can't talk to each other
that's what we have built but the
requirement is
the traffic needs to or they should be
able to talk to each other
but they should not have direct
connection between them
which means that they will have to come
and hit the vpc and then
reach the other customer network which
is in los angeles or which is in new
york
all right that's the requirement so
that's possible with some architecting
in the cloud so that's using vpn cloud
hub
you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate
networks to talk to each other through
the vpc
again by default it doesn't happen cloud
hub
is an architecture that we should be
using to make
this happen and what's the advantage of
it as
a central office or as the headquarters
office which is in the vpc
or headquarters data center which is in
the vpc you have control or the vpc has
control
on who talks to who and what traffic
can talk to i mean what traffic can be
routed to the other head office
stuff like that that centralized control
is on the vpc
the other question you could get asked
is name and explain some security
products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products
that can actually secure the vpc or
the vpc delivers those products to
secure
the application access to the vpc is
restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security
product in vpc and a vpc has security
groups
that protects the instances from
unwanted inbound and outbound traffic
and network access control list protects
the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access
and there are flow logs we can capture
in vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic
through a vpc which will be used for
later analysis
as in what's the traffic pattern what's
the behavior
of the traffic pattern and stuff like
that so there are some security
products and features available in vpc
now how do you monitor vpc vpc is a very
important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc
most of the service sits in a vpc except
for lambda
and s3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a vpc for
security reason
so how do you monitor your vpc how do
you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc
using vpc flow log that's the basic
service as you see
it actually captures what's allowed
what's not allowed
stuff like that which ip's allowed which
ip is not allowed
stuff like that so we can gather it and
we can use that
for analysis and the other one is cloud
watch and cloud watch logs the data
transfers
that happen so this is you know who gets
allowed and who does not get allowed i
mean
the flow logs is who is allowed and
who's not allowed
that kind of detail and cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer
how much data is getting transferred we
can actually
pick unusual data transfers if there is
a certain hike in the graph
there's a sudden hike and something
happens at 12
on a regular basis and you weren't
expecting it there's something
suspicious it could be valid backups
it could be a malicious activity as well
so that's how you know
by looking at cloudwatch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard
now let's talk about multiple choice
questions
when going for an interview you might
sometimes
find yourself that the company is
conducting
an online test based on the score they
can put you
to a panelist and then they would take
it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to
help you better handle such situation if
you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key
to clear them is to understand the
question properly
read between the lines that's what they
say you know there can be like
a big paragraph with three lines or ten
lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about
and then try to find answer for that
question so that's
a thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast
the services mentioned or try to compare
and contrast the answers
you can easily read out one or two
answers
and then you will be left with only two
answers
to decide from you know so that also
helps you with time and
that's all that also helps you with some
precision in your answer so
number one read between the lines number
two compare and contrast
the services and you'll be able to
easily weed out the wrong ones
so let's try answering this question
suppose you are a game designer and you
want to develop a game
with a single digit millisecond latency
which of the following database services
would you choose so we know that
the following are database services are
good enough all right
and it talks about millisecond latency
that's a key point
and the third thing is it's a game could
be a mobile game
it's a game that you are trying to
design and you need a
millisecond latency and it has to be a
database
all right so let's talk about the
options available rds rds is a database
for sure is it good for uh game design
we'll come back to that neptune uh
neptune is a
graph a database service in amazon so
that's kind of
out of the equation and snowball is
actually a
storage right it's it's a transport
medium i would say
so that's again out of the equation so
the tie is between rds and
dynamodb if we need to talk about rds
rds is an a platform as a service it
provides cost efficient resizable
capacity but
it's an sql database meaning the tables
are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other
type of applications but not really good
for anything that has to do with the
gaming so the only option left is
dynamodb
again it's the right answer dynamodb is
actually an
fast and flexible nosql database
service and it provides a single digit
millisecond latency at any scale
and it's a database at the same time
it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question
if you need to perform real-time
monitoring of aws services
and get actionable insights which
service
would you use all right let's list the
services
so it talks about real-time monitoring a
firewall manager
what does it provide now firewall
manager is
not really a monitor just like the name
says it's a manager
it manages multiple firewalls and aws
guard duty
is an thread detection service
it does monitoring it does continuously
monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about
cloud watch a cloud watch is a service
that
helps to track metrics it's a service
that
is used to monitor
the environment and give us a
system-wide
visibility and also it helps us to store
logs so
at the moment it kind of looks like that
could be the right answer we don't know
that yet but i mean we have one more
option left that's uh
ebs so what's ebs ebs is a block
storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so
all three of them are easily out of the
question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats of course
it does monitoring so there's
i mean if there is one relation between
cloud watch and guard duty that's
monitoring so easy we can
actually find ourselves slipped towards
picking guard duty but know that god
duty is only for
gaining security inside but not about
gaining
aws service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us
to get a system wide or an aws wide or
an account wide
it has number of metrics we can monitor
and get a very good insight of
how a service is performing be it cpu be
it
ram beat network utilization beat
connection failures
cloudwatch is a service that helps us
perform a real-time monitoring
and get some actionable insights on the
services
all right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform
all right there is a mention that this
is especially for the mobile platform
so a lot of services gets filtered out
mobile platform
right which of the following lets you
add user sign up sign
in and access control to your web and
mobile app
quickly and easily alright so this is
all about signing in
to your mobile app so if we need to read
between the lines that's how we can read
sign up
or sign in into a mobile platform all
right so we have like four options here
uh shield aws massey aws inspector
amazon cognito so let's try to weed out
services
which are not relevant to it so what's
aws shield aws shield is actually a
service that provides
a ddos mitigation or ddos protection
denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws
maxi is again a security service that
uses machine learning to automatically
discover and classify
the data it again talks about security
and
this security is all about encrypting or
saving the data
does not come close with signing up and
mobile platform
all right let's talk about the other one
aws inspector
now aws inspector has something to do
with
apps it definitely has something to do
with apps so
kind of looks like that's relevant as of
now so it actually helps with
the improving the security and
compliance of
the apps that we deploy in the cloud
so kind of looks like it could be
because it has to do with apps
the last one cognito now cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator
to have control access over
web and mobile apps and it's a service
that helps us to sign up
and assign in to an mobile and web app
so that very much
looks like we found the answer so
cognito is a service that helps
web app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also
gives the administrator to have control
over who has i mean access control over
the web and the mobile app pretty much
we found it so it's cognito cognito is a
service that
helps us to set up sign up sign in and
have access control
over the users who would be using our
mobile and web app all right how about
this question
you are an ml engineer or a machine
learning engineer
who is on the lookout for a solution
that will discover
sensitive information that your
enterprise stores
in aws and then uses nlp
to classify that data and provide
business
related insights which among the
following services would you choose so
we have
a bunch of services that's going to help
us achieve or one of it is going to help
us achieve
the about requirement so it's a service
that
deals with machine learning you're a
machine learning engineer
who's looking for a service that will
help you to discover information at your
enterprise store
so we're talking about storage discover
information in store
and then classify uh the data depending
on
severity the sensitivity classify the
data
so which service is that so firewall
manager just like the name says it's
a manager and the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access
management so it's identity and access
management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two
is already out of the equation then the
aw is massy
we already had a quick definition
description
for aws massey that it's actually a
security service that
uses machine learning kind of looks like
it could be it
it's a security service that uses
machine learning and it discovers and
classifies
the sensitive information not only that
it does not stop there
it goes beyond and protects the
sensitive data aws massey kind of looks
like but we still
have one more option to look at which is
cloud hms
cloud hms is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and
it enables us to generate encryption
keys
and save the data so kind of fifty
percent of it it's a security service
it encrypts helps us protect the data
but
aws maxi is right on spot it's a machine
learning service
it helps us to classify the data and
also to protect the data so the answer
for
this question would be aws messy so hope
you kind of get it how this is
going so first we apply the thumb rule
identify
the question that's being asked read
between the lines and then
try to find the service that meets your
requirement then
finding the service is by first weeding
out the wrong ones
recollect everything that you've learned
about the service
and see how well that matches with those
hints that you have
picked up and if that doesn't match weed
that out then you'll end up with
two just to to decide from at some point
and then it becomes easy for you to
decide click on the question
submit it and then move on to the other
question in your interview
right so how about this one you are a
system administrator in your company
which is running most of its
infrastructure on aws
you are required to track your users and
keep
a look on how your users are being
authenticated all right so this is where
the problem statement starts
right you need to keep track of how your
users are being authenticated and you
wish to create and manage
aws users and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to the aws
resources right
you are to give them permission number
one
and then i mean if we put them in the
right order first giving them
permissions and then tracking their
usage let's see which of the service
will help us achieve it
iam is a service that helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not
so that helps us to get a track of who
is able to use who's
not able to use certain servers and all
that stuff so it kind of looks like
but we have other three options left
let's look at aws firewall manager just
like the name says it's actually a
firewall manager it helps us to manage
multiple firewalls simple as that
and shield is a service it's a service
that's used to protect
denial of service or distributed denial
of
service an api gateway is a service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish
maintain and monitor and secure
api so i mean it's completely on the api
side
very less on user and how you
authenticate
your user we can get that by looking at
the name itself
right if we abbreviate it or if we if
you try to find a definition
for the name api gateway you would get
it it has to do with api
but if we aggregate aws iam its identity
and access management
pretty much meets the requirement for
the problem statement about its aws
identity and access management that's
the right answer all right let's look at
this one if you want to allocate various
private and public ip address
in order to make them communicate with
the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using
public and private ip address so this
service
uses ip address and then this service
helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and
to the other instances so you get the
question is it
let's pick the service that helps us
achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or
deny no it does not do that vpc vpc uses
public and private ip address
yes so kind of looks like a vpc
helps us to allow i mean the security in
vpc the security group the network
access control list in a vpc that
routing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection
to a particular ip address or to a
particular service within
the vpc or outside of the vpc so as of
now it kind of looks like
it could be but let's look at the other
services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches
to the above requirement than the amazon
vpc
gateway api gateway we know that it's a
managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish
maintain and monitor apis and secure api
so that has
completely do with api not with ib
cloudfront we know about cloudfront that
it's a content delivery network and it
provides
global distribution of servers
where our content can be cached it could
be video or bulk media or anything else
they can be cached locally so users can
easily access them and
download them easily right so that's
cloud front
now at this point after looking at all
four it looks like vpc is the right
answer and in fact vpc is the right
answer vpc has public ip address vpc can
help us with
private ip address vpc can be used to
allow
deny connection based on the security
group access control list
and routing table it has so that's right
answer is vpc
all right how about this one this
platform as a service
or platform as a db service provides us
with the cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative
tasks so this question is very clear
it's a db service we got to look for
and it's a service that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
tasks it has to be
resizable at the same time so let's talk
about amazon rational
database it's a database kind of matches
the requirement
we can resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now
it actually automates some of the time
consuming work
looks like it's a fit as of now let's
move on to elastic cache and then
try to see if that matches the
definition
that we've figured out about elastic
cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving
high throughput and low latency in
memory data stores so it's not a
full-blown
database and it does not come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything
like that yeah we can resize the
capacity as and when needed but
automation it's not there yet and
moreover it's not a database so
that's out of the equation vpc is not
a recessible one you know once we have
designed vpc
it's fixed it can't be resized so that's
out of the equation and uh amazon
glacier
glacier is a storage but not a database
all right so that's again of the
equation so that tie is kind of between
amazon rational database service and
amazon elastic cache
because they both aid the database
service but elastic cache
is not a full-blown database it actually
helps database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's amazon
relational database so that's the one
which is a platform as a service
it's the one which can be resized it's
the one which
can be used to automate the
time consuming administrative tasks all
right let's talk about this one
which of the following is a means for
accessing human researchers
or consultants to help solve a problem
on a
contractual or a temporary basis
all right let's read the question again
which of the following is a means for
accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts
for a temporary job so let's try to find
that kind of service in the four
services that are listed
amazon elastic mapreduce mapreduce is
actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost
effective to analyze large amount of
data but
that has nothing to do with accessing
human researchers
all right let's talk about mechanical
term it's a web service that provides
a human workforce that's the definition
for it
for example automation is good but not
everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be
an repeative task one time task can't be
automated or
the time and money that you would be
spending in automation is not worth it
instead you could have done it manually
so that does not qualify for automation
and anything that requires
intelligence right anything that's a
special case
right automation can do repetitive tasks
automation can do precise work but
it has to be repetitive tasks the
scenario you know it should have been
there already
only then that can be executed but if
it's a new scenario and it requires
uh appropriate addressing then it
requires human thought so
we could hire researchers and
consultants who can help solve a problem
using amazon
mechanical turk the other two are
already out of the equation
now dev pay is actually a payment system
through amazon
and multi-factor authentication as it
says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is amazon mechanical
turk
all right this sounds interesting let's
look at this one this service is used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws
which of the following is this aws
service so it's a service to deploy
manage
and scale containerized applications so
it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is and container
orchestration
service all right the first one amazon
elastic container service
kind of looks like it's the one the name
itself has
the word and the relation we're looking
for elastic
container service so this container
service is an
highly scalable high performance
container orchestration service
let's look at the other one aws batch
it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock
that's another service that helps us to
deploy manage
and scale but it helps us with easy two
instances
not with containerized instances so
that's
again out of the equation would light
scale be a good time
for elastic container service what's
light sale
now lightsail is a service it's called
as
a virtual private server without a vpc
it's called as a virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage
networking capacity it's actually a
server
not a container right so at this point
that also
becomes out of the equation so it's
amazon elastic container service that's
the one that helps us to
easily deploy manage scale container
services
and it helps us orchestrate the
containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service
lets us to run code without provisioning
or
managing servers no servers run code
select the correct service
from the below option all right so no
servers but we should be able to run
code amazon easy to auto scaling easy to
auto scaling
ec2 is elastic compute cloud which is
a server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling
the server so that's the definition for
it could be
that's out of the equation aw is lambda
now lambda
is a service it's actually an event
driven serverless computing platform
and lambda runs code in response to the
event
that it receives and it automatically
manages the
compute resource that's required for
that code
as long as we have uploaded a code
that's correct and set up
events correctly to map to that code
it's going to run
seamlessly so that's about lambda it
kind of looks like it could be the
answer because
lambda runs code we don't have to manage
servers it
manages servers by itself but we can't
conclude as of now we have other two
servers to talk about
aws batch all right batches service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that
and about inspector amazon inspector
it's actually a service that helps us to
increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance
well that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement in the question
was
run code without provisioning your
server and without any more space for
confusion
aws lambda is a service or is the
service that runs code without
provisioning and managing
services right the right one would be
aws lambda all right so by this we have
come to the end of the first
section if getting your learning started
is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
i'm glad that we were able to provide
you a second part in aws
interview questions all right let's get
started so in an environment where
there's a lot of automation
infrastructure automation
you'll be posted with this question how
can you add an existing
instance to a new auto scaling group now
this is when
you are taking an instance away from the
auto scaling group
to troubleshoot to fix a problem
you know to look at logs or if you have
suspended the auto scaling you know you
might need to
re-add that instance to the auto scaling
group only then it's going to take part
in it right only then the auto scaling
is going to count it has
part of it it's not a straight uh
procedure you know when you remove them
you know it doesn't get automatically
re-added i've had
worked with some clients so when their
developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance
back to the auto scaling group you know
irrespective of what they tried the
instance was
not getting added to the auto scaling
group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
we're not you know getting encountered
in the auto scaling group so
like i said it's not a straight you know
a click button procedure there are ways
we'll have to do it so how can you add
an
existing instance to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that
we need to follow so the first one would
be to under the ec2
instance console right under the uh
instance
under actions in specific you know
there's an option
called attach to auto skilling group
right if you have multiple auto scaling
groups
in your account or in the region that
you're working in
then you're going to be posted with the
different auto scaling groups that you
have in your account
let's say you have five auto scaling
groups for five different application
you know you're going to be posted with
five different auto scaling
groups and then you would select the
auto scaling
the appropriate auto scaling group and
attach the instance to that particular
auto scaling group while adding to the
auto scaling group if you want to change
the instance
type you know that's possible as well
sometimes
when you want to add the instance back
to the auto skilling group there would
be
requirement that you change the instance
type to a better one to a better family
to the better instance type
you could do that at that time and after
that you are
or you have completely added the
instance back to the auto scaling group
so it's actually an seven step up
process adding an instance back
to the auto scaling group in an
environment where
they're dealing with migrating the
instance or migrating an application or
migrating an instance migrating an vm
into the cloud you know if the project
that you're going to work with deals
with a lot of migrations
you could be posted this question what
are the factors you will consider
while migrating to amazon web services
the first one is
cost is it worth moving the
instance to the cloud given the
additional
builds and results features available in
the cloud
is this application going to use all of
them is moving into the cloud
beneficial to the application in the
first place you know beneficial to the
users who will be using the application
in the first place so that's a factor to
think of
so this actually includes you know cost
of the infrastructure
and the ability to match the demand and
supply transparency
is this application and high demand you
know is it going to be a big loss
if the application becomes unavailable
for some time so there are a few things
that needs to be considered before we
move the application
to the cloud and then if the application
does the application
needs to be provisioned immediately is
that an urge
is there an urge to provision the
application
immediately that's something that needs
to be considered if
the application requires to go online
if the application needs to hit the
market immediately
then we would need to move it to the
cloud because in on premises
procuring buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their software's buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application
in it right so if the application cannot
wait
you know waiting means uh you know
workforce productivity loss
is it so we would want to immediately
launch instances and put application on
top of it in those case
if if your application is of that type
if there is a urge in making the
application
go online as soon as possible then
that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if
the uh the software or if the product
that you're launching
it requires hardware it requires an
updated hardware all the time that's not
going to be possible in on premises
we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time
in on premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardware only
then they can
keep themselves up going in the market
so they constantly the cloud providers
are constantly updating
their hardwares and if you want to be
benefited of your application wants to
be benefited by the constant
upgrading of the hardwares making sure
the hardware is
as latest as possible the software
version
the licensing is as latest as possible
then that's a candidate to be moved to
the cloud
and if the application does not want to
go through any risk if the application
is
very sensitive to failures if the
application is
very much stacked to the revenue of the
company and you don't want to take a
chance
in you know seeing the application fail
and you know seeing the revenue drop
then that's a candidate for moving to
the cloud and business
agility you know moving to the cloud at
least half of the responsibility is now
taken care
by the provider in this case it's amazon
at least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if
the hardware fails amazon makes sure
that they're fixing the hardware
immediately and notifications you know
if something happens
you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and
make yourself aware that something has
broken
and we can immediately jump in and fix
it so you see there are
the responsibility is now being shared
between amazon and
us so if you want to get that benefit
for your application for your
organization
for the product that you're launching
then it needs to be moved to the cloud
so you can get that benefit
from the cloud the other question you
could get asked is what is rto
and rpo in aws they are essentially
disaster recovery terms when you're
planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about rto and
rpo now what's the rto what's the rpo
in your environment or how do you define
rto how do you define rpo or some
general questions
that get asked rto is recovery time
objective rto stands for the maximum
time
the company is willing to wait for the
recovery
to happen or for the recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is
in the future right how much time is it
going to take
to fix and bring everything to normal so
that's rto
on the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is
the maximum amount of data laws your
company is willing
to accept as measured in time rpo always
refers to the backups the number of
backups
the the frequency of the backups right
because when an outage
happens you can always go back to the
latest
backup right and if the latest backup
was before 12 hours
you have lost the in between 12 hours of
data data storage right so rpo is the
acceptable amount
if the company wants less rpo
rpo is 1r then you should be planning on
taking backups every one hour
if rpo is 12 hours then you should be
planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how
rpo and rto you know helps disaster
recovery the fourth question you could
get asked is
if you'd like to transfer huge amount of
data which is the best
option among a snowball snowball edge
and
snowmobile again this is a question that
gets asked if
the company is dealing with a lot of
data transfer
into the cloud or if the company is
dealing with the
migrating data into the cloud i'm
talking about a huge amount of data data
in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte-sized
data migrations so there are three
options available as of now
aws snowball is an data transport
solution
for moving high volume of data into and
out of
a specified aws region on the other hand
aws snowball
edge adds additional computing functions
snowball is simple storage and movement
of data and snowball edge has
a compute function attached to it snow
mobile
on the other hand is an exabyte scale
migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like
100 000 terabytes so depending on the
size of data that
we want to transfer from our data center
to the cloud
we can hire we can rent any of these
three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is aws cloud formation
different from aws elastic beanstalk you
know from the surface
they both look like the same you know
you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli
and provision resources both of them
provision resources
through click button right but
underneath they
are actually different services they
support
they aid different services so knowing
that is going to help you understand
this question a lot
better let's talk about the difference
between them and this is what you will
be explaining
to the interviewer or the panelist so
the cloud formation
the cloud formation service helps you
describe and
provision all the infrastructure
resources in the cloud environment
on the other hand elastic bean stock
provides
an simple environment to which we can
deploy
and run application cloud formation
gives us
an infrastructure and elastic bean stock
gives us an
small contained environment in which we
can run
our application and cloud formation
supports the infrastructure needs
of many different types of application
like
the enterprise application the legacy
applications
and any new modern application that you
want to have in the cloud
on the other hand the elastic bean stock
it's
a combination of developer tools they
are tools that helps
manage the life cycle of a single
application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure
as a whole and elastic bean stock in
short is
managing and running an application in
the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using uh cloud formation
to manage their infrastructure using or
if they're using infrastructure
or any of the infrastructure as a code
services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an aws cloud
formation
template so it has four or five
basic elements right and the template is
in the form of
json or in yaml
format all right so it has parameters it
has
outputs it has data it has resources
and then the format or the format
version
or the file format version for the cloud
formation
template so parameter is nothing but it
actually lets you to specify the type of
ec2 instance
that you want the type of rds that you
want
all right so ec2 is an umbrella rds is
an
umbrella and parameters within that ec2
and parameters within that rds are the
specific details
of the ec2 or the specific details of
the rds service so that's what
parameters in a
cloud formation template and then the
element of the cloud formation template
is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of
an s3 bucket that was created if you
want to output the name of the ec2
instance if you want to output the name
of
some resources that have been created
instead of looking into the template
instead of
you know navigating through in the
console and finding the name of the
resource we can actually have them
outputted in at the result section
so we can simply go and look at all the
resources
created through the template in the
output section and that's what output
values or output does in the cloud
formation template and then we have
resources resources are nothing but what
defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources
that will be created through this cloud
formation template now ec2 is a resource
rds
is a resource and s3 bucket is a
resource
elastic load balancer is a resource and
nat gateway is a resource
vpc is a reserve so you see all these
components are the resources
and the resource section in the cloud
formation defines what are the
aws cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation
template and then we have a version a
version actually identifies the
capabilities of the template you know we
just need to make sure that it is of the
latest version type and the latest
version is
0 9 0 9 2010 that's the latest version
number
you'll be able to find that on the top
of the cloud formation template and that
version number defines the capabilities
of the cloud formation template so just
need to make sure that it's the latest
all the time
still talking about cloud formation this
is another classic question
what happens when one of the resource in
a stack cannot be created
successfully well if the resource in a
stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back
and terminates all the resources that
was created
using the cloud formation template so
whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning
let's say we have created like 10
resources and the 11th resource is now
failing
cloudformation will roll back and delete
all
the 10 resources that were created
previously and this is very useful uh
when
the cloud formation cannot you know go
forward cloud formation cannot create
additional resources because
we have reached the elastic ip limits
elastic ip limit per region is five
right and if you have already used
five ips and your cloud formation is
trying to
buy three more ips you know we've hit
the soft limit
till we fix that with amazon cloud
formation will not be able to
you know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with
a missing ec2 ami as well if
an ami is included in the template and
but the
ami is not actually present then cloud
formation is going to
search for the mi and because it's not
present it's going to roll back
and delete all the resources that it uh
created so that's what
cloudformation does it simply rolls back
all the resources that it
created i mean if it sees a failure it
would simply roll back all the resources
that it
created and this feature actually
simplifies
the system administration and layered
solutions built on top of aws cloud
formation
so at any point we know that there are
no orphan
resources in the in in our environment
you know because something did not work
or because there was an you know cloud
formation
executed some there are no orphan
resources in our account
at any point we can be sure that if
cloud formation is launching a resource
and if it's going to fail and it's going
to come back and delete all the
resources
it's created so there are no orphan
resources in our account
now let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store
again if the environment deals with a
lot of automation
you could be thrown this question how
can you automate easy to backup using
ebs it's actually a six step process to
automate the ec2 backups we'll need to
write a script
to automate the below steps using aws
api
and these are the steps that should be
found in the scripts
first to get the list of instances and
then and then the script that we are
writing
should be able to connect to aws using
the api
and list the amazon abs volumes that are
attached
locally to the instance and then it
needs to list
the snapshots of each volume make sure
the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because
you have captured the latest and 10
snapshot coverage is enough for you
and then the fifth point is to create a
snapshot
of each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot anytime a new snapshot gets
created the oldest
snapshot of the list needs to go away so
we need to include
options we need to include scripts in
our script lines in our script
that make sure that it's deleting the
older
snapshots which are older than the
retention period
that we are mentioning another question
that you could
see in the interview be it a written
interview beat online interview or beat
and telephonic or face-to-face interview
is what's the difference between
ebs and instant store let's talk about
ebs
first ebs is kind of permanent storage
the data in it can be restored at a
later point
when we save data in ebs the data lives
even after the lifetime of the ec2
instance for example we can stop the
instance
and the data is still going to be
present in ebs we can move the ebs from
one instance to another instance and the
data is simply going to be present there
so abs is kind of permanent storage when
compared
to instance on the other hand instance
store
is a temporary storage and that storage
is actually physically attached to the
host of the machine
ebs is an external storage an instant
store is locally attached
to the instance or locally attached to
the host of
the machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that
with eba so that's a big difference one
is permanent data
and another one is ebs is permanent
instant store is
a volatile data and instant store with
instant store we won't be able to
detach the storage and attach it to
another instance and another feature of
instant store is data in an instant
store is lost
if the disk fails or the instance is
stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cash
data if you want to store permanent data
then we should think of using ebs
and not instant store while talking
about storage on the same lines this is
another classic question
how can you take backups of efs like
ebs and if you can take backup how do
you take
that backup the answer is yes we can
take efs to efs backup solution
efs does not support snapshot like ebs
efs does not support snapshot snapshot
is not an option for
efs elastic file system right we can
only take backup from one efs
to another efs and this backup solution
is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of
the efs and this can be automated but
any data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or
you know the whole ef is is for some
reason interrupted or deleted
we can recover the data from we can use
the other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this
it's not an one step configuration it's
a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve
efs to efs backup the first thing is to
sign in to the aws management console
and
under efs or click on efs to efs
restore button from the services list
and from there
we can use the region selector in the
console navigation bar to select the
actual
region in which we want to work on and
from there
ensure that we have selected the right
template you know some of the templates
would be you know efs to efs backup
granular backups incremental backups
right so there are some templates the
kind of backups that you want to take do
you want to take grant alert do you want
to take
increment backups stuff like that and
then
create a name to that solution the kind
of backup that we have created
and finally review all the
configurations that you have done and
click
on save and from that point onwards the
data is going to be copied
and from that point onwards any
additional data that you put
is going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an efs to efs
backup this is another classic question
in companies which deals with
a data management there are easy options
to create snapshots
but deleting snapshots is
not always an you know click button or a
single step configuration so you might
be facing a question like how do you
auto delete
old snapshots and the procedure is like
this
now as best practice we will take
snapshots of ebs volume to s3
all snapshots get stored in s3 we know
that now and
we can use aws ops automator to
automatically
handle all snapshots the ops automator
service it allows us to create
copy delete ebs snapshots
so there are cloud formation templates
available for aws
ops automator and this automator
template
will scan the environment and it would
take snapshots it would you know copy
the snapshot from one region to another
region if you want i know if you're
setting up a dr environment and not only
that based on the retention period
that we create it's going to delete the
snapshots which are older than
the retention period so life or managing
snapshot
is made a lot easier because of this ops
automator
cloud formation template moving into
questions and elastic
load balancer this again could be an
question in the interview what are the
different types of load balancers in aws
and
what's their use case what's the
difference between them and as of now as
we speak there are three types of load
balancers
which are available in aws the first one
being application
load balancer just like the name says
the application load balancer works on
the application layer and deals with the
http and https
request and it it also supports part
based routing for example
simplylearn.com
slash some webpage simplylearn.com slash
another website so it's going to direct
the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the urls that's path based
routing so it supports that and not only
that it can support a port based
colon 8080 colon 8081 or colon
8090 you know based on that port also
it can take a routing decision and
that's what application load balancer
does
on the other hand we have network load
balancer and
the network load balancer makes routing
decisions at the transport level it's
faster because it has very less thing to
work on
it works on lower osi layer it works on
a lower layer so it has very less
information to work with
than compared with application layer so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives a
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the
flow hash routing algorithm it does
simple routing
right it does not do path based or port
based routing
it does simple routing and because of it
it's faster and then we have
classic load balancer which is kind of
expiring
as we speak amazon is discouraging
people using classic load balancer but
there are companies
which are still using classic load
balancer they are the ones
who are the first one to step into
amazon when classic load balancer was
the first load balancer or the only load
balancer available at that point so it
supports
http https tcp ssl
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between a load balance report and the
container port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then
at after some point amazon said instead
of having one load balancer address all
type of traffic we're going to have
two load balances called as the child
from the classic two load balancer and
one is going to
specifically address the application
requirement and one is going to
specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how
now we have two different load balancers
talking about load balancer another
classic question could be
what are the different uses of the
various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just spoke
about it
application load balancer is used if we
need flexible application management and
tls termination and network load
balancer
if we require extreme performance and
the load balancing should happen
on based on static ips for the
application
and classic load balancer is an old load
balancer
which is for people who are still
running their environment from easy to
classic network now
this is an older version of vpc or this
is what was present
before vpc was created easy to classic
network is what
was present before ec2 was created so
they are the three types
and they are the use cases of it let's
talk about some of the
security related questions you would
face in the interview
when talking about security and firewall
in aws we
cannot avoid discussion talking about
waff
web application firewall and you would
definitely
see yourself in this situation where
you've been asked
how can you use aws vaf in monitoring
your aws
applications waf or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common
web exploits and vaf helps us control
which traffic source your application
should be allowed or
a block which traffic from a certain
source you know which source or which
traffic from a certain source should be
allowed or blocked your application
with waff we can also create custom
rules
that blocks common attack patterns you
know if it is a banking application it
has a
certain type of attacks and if it is
simple uh data management data storage
application it has
uh i mean content management application
it has a separate type of attack so
based on
the application type we can identify a
pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that
we create and waff can be used
for three cases you know the first one
is allow all requests
and then block all request and count all
requests
for a new policy so it's also an
monitoring and management service
which actually counts all the policies
or
counts all the requests that matches a
particular policy that we create
and some of the characteristics we can
mention in aws off
are the origin ips and the strings that
appear in the request we can allow
block based on origin ip allow block
based on strings that appear in the
request we can allow block
or count based on the origin country
length of the request
yeah we can block and count the presence
of malicious scripts
in an connection you know we can count
the request headers or we can allow
block a certain
request header and we can count the
presence of
a malicious sql code in a connection
that we get and that want to
reach our application still talking
about security what are the different
aws im categories we can control using
aws iam
we can do the following one is create
and manage im users
and once the user database gets bigger
and bigger we can create and manage them
in groups
and in im we can use it
to manage the security credentials kind
of setting the complexity of the
password
you know setting additional
authentications you know like
mfa and you know rotating the passwords
no resetting the password
there are few things we could do with
iam and finally we can create
policies that actually grants access to
aw services and
resources another question you will see
is what are the policies that you can
set for your users password so some of
the policies that we can set for the
user password
is at the minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters
in the password so that's one and then
the requirement of a specific
character types including you know
uppercase lowercase
number and non-alphabetic characters so
it becomes very hard for
somebody else to guess what the password
uh would be
and and try to hack them so we can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity
in the password and then we can set an
automatic
expiration of the password so after a
certain time the user
is forced to create a new password so
the password is not stale
old and easy to guess in the environment
and we can also set
settings like the user should contact
the admin
i mean when the password is about to
expire so
you know you can get a hold of how the
user is setting
their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards
or there are few things that we can
control and set for the users when the
users are
setting or recreating the password
another question
that could be posted in an interview so
to understand your
understanding of iem is what's the
difference between
an iem role and an im user let's talk
about im
let's start small and then go big or
let's start simple and then
talk about the complex one the iem user
has
a permanent long-term credential and
it's used to interact directly
with aws services and on the other hand
iem
role is an iem entity that defines a set
of permissions for making aws
service requests so im user is an
permanent credential
and role are temporary credentials and
iem user has full access to
all aws im functionalities and with role
trusted entities such as iem users
application or aws services
uh assume of the role so when an iem
user is given an
permission you know it sticks within the
iem
user but with roles we can give
permissions to
applications we can give permissions to
users in the same account in a different
account a corporate id
we can give permissions to ec2 s3
rds vpc and lot more role is wide
and im user is is not so wide
you know it's very constrained only for
that im
user let's talk about managed policies
in aws
managed policies there are two types you
know customer managed and
amazon managed so manage policies are
im resources that express permissions
using the iam
policy language now we can create
policies
edit them manage them manage them
separately from
the im user group and roles which they
are
attached to so they are something that
we can do to managed policies if it is
customer managed
and we can now update policy in one
place and
the permissions automatically extend to
all the attached entries
so i can have like three services four
services point to a particular policy
and if i edit that particular policy
it's going to reflect on those three or
four services so anything that i allow
is going to be allowed for those four
services anything that i denied is going
to be denied for
the four services imagine what would be
without the
im managed policy will have to go and
specifically allow deny
on those different instances four or
five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like i said there are
two types of managed policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policies and then the other is managed
by aws
which is aws managed policy this
question can you give an example of an
iem policy and a policy summary this is
actually to test
how well versed are you with the aws
console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to grant
access to add update and delete objects
from a specific folder now in this case
name of the folder is
example folder and it's present in a
bucket called
example bucket so this is an iam policy
on the other hand the policy summary is
a list of
access level resource and conditions for
each service
defined in a policy so im policy is
all about one particular resource and
the policy summary
is all about multiple resources with im
policy it was only talking about s3
bucket and one particular s3 bucket here
it talks about cloud formation template
cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them
that's what policy summary is all about
another question could be like this
what's the use case of
iam and how does im help
your business two important or primary
work of im is to help us manage iam
users
and their access it provides a secure
access to multiple users
to their appropriate aws resources so
that's one
it does and the second thing it does is
manage access for
federated users federated users or non
iam users and through iam we can
actually
allow and provide a secured access to
resources
in our aws account to our employees
without the im user no they could be
authenticated using the active directory
they could be authenticated using the
facebook credential
google credential amazon credential and
a couple of other credentials third
party
identity management right so we could
actually trust them
and we could give them access to our
account based on
the trust relationship that we have
built with the
other identity of systems all right so
two things one is
manage users and their access for uh
manage iam user and their access in our
aws environment and second
is manage access for federated users
who are non-iam users and more
importantly im is a free service
and with that will only be charged for
the
use of the resources not for the im
username and password that we create all
right let's now
talk about some of the questions in
route 53.
one classic question that could be asked
in an interview is what is the
difference between
latency based routing and geodns or
jio based dns routing now the jio based
dns routing takes routing decisions on
the basis of the geographic location of
the request and on the other hand the
latency based
routing utilizes latency measurements
between
networks and data centers now
latency-based
routing is used where you want to give
your customers
the lowest latency as possible so that's
when we would use
latency based routing and on the other
hand the geo-based routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites
based on the country they are browsing
from
you know you could have you know two
different or three different websites
for the same url you know take amazon
the shopping website for example
when we go to amazon.com from in the us
it directs us to the us web page where
the products are different
the currency is different right and the
flag and a couple of other
advertisements that shows up
are different and when we go to
amazon.com from
india it gets directed to the amazon.com
indian site where again the currency the
product and the advertisements
they're all different right so depending
on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites
we would use a geo-based routing another
use case of geo-based routing
is if you have a compliance that you
should handle all
the dns requires sorry if you should
handle all the
uh requests you know from a country
within the country
then you would do jio based routing now
you wouldn't
direct the customer to a server which is
in another country
right you would direct the customer to a
server which is very local to them
that's another use case of jio based
routing and like i said for
latency based routing the whole goal or
aim
is to achieve minimum end user latency
if you are hired for the architect role
and
if that requires working lot on the dns
then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted zone a domain is
actually a collection of
data describing a self-contained
administrative
and technical unit on the internet right
so for example you know
simplylearn.com is actually a domain on
the other hand
hosted zone is actually an container
that
holds information about how you want to
route
traffic on the internet to a specific
domain for example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted zone
whereas
simplylearn.com is a domain so in other
words in hosted zone
you would see the domain name plus and a
prefix
to it lms is a prefix here ftp is a
prefix
mail.simplylearn.com is a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from route 53
would be
how does amazon drop 53 provide high
availability and
low latency the way amazon route 53
provides high availability and low
latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services
globally any customer doing a query from
different parts of the world they get to
reach
an dns server which is very local to
them and that's how
it provides low latency now this is not
true with
all the dns providers there are dns
providers who are
very local to a country who are very
local to a continent so they don't
they generally don't provide low latency
service
right it's always high latency it's low
latency for
local users but anybody browsing from a
different country or a different
continent it's going to be high latency
for them
but that's not again true with amazon
amazon
is a globally distributed dns provider
it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has
optimal locations it has got global
servers
or in other words it has got servers
around the globe different parts in the
globe and
that's how they are able to provide high
availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers
they provide high availability and low
latency if the environment that you're
going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups
then you can expect questions in aws
config a classic question would be how
does aws config work along with aws
cloudtrail aws cloudtrail actually
records user api activity on the account
and you know any http https access or
any any sort of access you know that's
made to the cloud environment that's
recorded
in the cloud trail in other words any
api calls
the time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in
cloud trail it's actually a log it
actually records
uh the activity in your cloud
environment on the other hand
config is an uh point in time
configuration details of your resources
for example at a given point what are
all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources
or what are the configuration in those
resources
at a given point they get captured in
aws conflict right so with that
information
you can always answer the question what
did my aws resource
look like at a given point in time that
question gets answered
when we use aws config on the other hand
with cloudtrail
you can answer the question i mean by
looking at the cloud trail or with the
help of
cloudtrail you can easily answer the
question who made an apa call
to modify this resource that's answered
by
cloudtrail and with the cloud trail we
can detect if a
security group was incorrectly
configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happen to
be a downtime and you want to identify
let's say there happen to be a downtime
and you want to identify
who made that change in the environment
you can simply look at cloudtrail
and find out who made the change and if
you want to look at how the environment
looks like
before the change you can always look at
aws config can aws configure
or aws config aggregate data across
different aws accounts
yes it can now this question is actually
to test whether you have used aws config
or not i know some of the services are
very local is it some of these services
are availability zone specific some of
them are regional specific
and some of them are global services in
amazon
and though some of the services are
region services you still
can do some changes you know add some
configuration to it and collect
regional data in it for example s3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect
logs from all other regions into an s3
bucket in one particular region that's
possible
and cloud trail is and cloud watch is an
regional service but still
you can with some changes to it with
some adding permissions to it
you can always monitor the cloud watch
that belongs to cloudwatch logs
that belongs to other regions you know
they're not global by default but
you can do some changes and make it
global similarly aws config is a service
that's a region based service but still
you can make it act globally you can
aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts
in an aws config and deliver
the updates from different accounts to
one
s3 bucket and can access it from there
aws config also works or integrates
seamlessly with sns topic so you know
anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about
the new log or the new config or new
edit that happened
in the environment let's look at some of
the database questions
you know database should be running on
reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer
wants to understand how well you know
that fact by asking this question how
are reserved instances different from
on-demand
db instances reserved instances and
on-demand instances
are exactly the same when it comes to
their function but they only differ
based on how they are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low
uh per hour pricing because we're paying
upfront
it's generally said that uh reserved
instance is 75 percentage cheaper
than on-demand instance and amazon gives
you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year
on the other hand on-demand instances
are built on an oddly early price
talking about auto scaling how will you
understand the different types of auto
scaling the interviewer might ask this
question which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and
y the two types of scaling as you would
know now
are vertical and horizontal and in
vertical scaling we can
vertically scale up the master database
with
a couple of clicks all right so that's
vertical scaling vertical scaling is
keeping the same node and making it
bigger
and bigger if previously it was running
on t2 micro now
we would like to run it on m3 two times
large
instance previously it had one virtual
cpu one gigabit
now it's going to have eight virtual cpu
and 30 gigabit
of ram so that's vertical scaling on the
other hand horizontal scaling is adding
more nodes to it previously it was
running on one vm now it's going to run
on 2
3 10 vms all right that's horizontal
scaling so database can only be scaled
vertically and there are 18
different types of instances we can
resize our rds2 right so this is true
for
ideas mysql postgres sql mariadb
oracle microsoft sql servers there are
18 type of instances we can vertically
scale up
to on the other hand horizontal scaling
are good for
replicas so they are read only replicas
we're not
going to touch the master database we're
not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling
only with amazon aurora and i can add
additional read replicas i can add up to
15
read replicas for amazon aurora and up
to five
read replicas for rds mysql postgres
sql and marie db rds instances
and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more
nodes right read only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide
between vertical and horizontal scaling
if you're looking
in to increase the storage and the
processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you're looking at increasing the
performance
or of the read heavy database we need to
be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing
horizontal scaling in our environment
still talking about database this is
another
good question you can expect in the
interview what is a maintenance window
in amazon rds
will your db instance be available
during the maintenance
event all right so this is really to
test how well you have understood the
sla
how well you have understood the amazon
rdas the failover mechanism of amazon
rdas
uh stuff like that so audio's
maintenance window it lets you decide
when a db instance modification a
database engine upgrades
or software uh patching has to occur and
you you actually get to decide should it
happen at 12 in the night or should it
happen at
afternoon should it happen early in the
morning should it happen
in the evening you actually get to
decide an automatic scheduling
by amazon is done only for patches that
are security
and durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and
durability and by default the
maintenance window is
is for 30 minutes and the important
point is
the db instance will be available during
that
event because you're gonna have primary
and secondary right so when that upgrade
happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade
and then switch back to the primary
another classic question would be what
are the consistency models
in dynamodb in dynamodb there is
eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model
it actually maximizes your read
throughput
and the best part with eventual
consistency is all copies of data
reach a consistency within a second
and sometimes when you write and when
you're you know trying to read
immediately
chances that you would still be reading
the old data
that's eventual consistency on the other
hand there is
another consistency model called the
strong consistency or strongly
read where there is going to be a delay
in writing the data
you know making sure the data is written
in all places but
it guarantees one thing that is once you
have done a write
and then you're trying to do a read it's
going to make sure that
it's going to show you the updated data
not the old data and you can be
guaranteed of it that it is going to
show
the updated data and not the old data
that's strongly consistent
still talking about database talking
about nosql dynamodb or nosql database
which is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of
query functionality does dynamodb
support dynamodb supports get and
put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb
provides flexible querying by letting
you query on
non-primary key attributes using
global secondary index and local
secondary indexes
a primary key can be either a single
attribute partition key or a
composite partition sort key in other
words a dynamodb indexes a composite
partition
sort key as a partition key element and
a sort key element
and by holding the partition key you
know when doing a search or when doing a
query by holding the partition key
element constant we can search across
the sort key element
to retrieve the other items in that
table and
the composite partition sort key should
be a combination of a user id
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition
sort key is made of let's look at some
of the multiple choice questions you
know sometimes some companies
would have an a written test or an mcq
type
online test before they call you for at
the first level or before they call you
for the second level so these are some
classical questions that
companies asked or companies ask in
their
multiple choice online questions let's
look at this question as a developer
using this pay-per-use service you can
send
store and receive messages between
software components which of the
following is being
referred here let's look at it right we
have aws step functions
amazon mq amazon simple queue service
amazon
simple notification service let's read
the question again as a developer using
this pay-per-use service
so the service that we are looking for
is a pay-per-view service
you can send store and retrieve messages
between two software components kind of
like a queue there
so what would be the right answer it
would be amazon simple queue service
now amazon simply queue service is the
one that's used to decouple
at the environment it breaks the tight
coupling and then it
introduces decoupling in that
environment by providing a cue
or by inserting a cue between two
software components
let's look at this other question if you
would like to host a real-time audio and
video conferencing application
on aws it's an audio and video
conferencing application on aws
this service provides you with a secure
and easy to use
application what is this service let's
look at the options they are
amazon chime amazon workspace
amazon mq amazon app stream but you
might tend to look at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference
but it's actually for a different
purpose is actually amazon
chime that lets you create chat and
create a chat board
and then collaborate with the security
of
the aws services so it lets you do the
audio it's lets you do the video
conference all supported by aws
security features it's actually amazon
chime let's look at this question
as your company's aws solution architect
you are in charge of designing
thousands of individual jobs which are
similar which of the following service
best serves
your requirement in earlier ec2 auto
scaling
aws snowball aws fargate aws badge
let's read the question again as your
company's aws solution
architect you are in charge of designing
thousands of
individual jobs which are similar it
looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an
storage transport service ec2 auto
scaling is uh
you know in introducing scalability and
elasticity in the environment and aws
far gate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are
similar aws batch it's the right answer
let's look at the
other one you are a machine learning
engineer and you're looking for a
service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in
aws which among the following are we
referring to so we have amazon sage
maker
aws deep lens amazon comprehend
aws device farm let's read the question
again you are a machine learning
engineer and you're looking for a
service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in aws
which among the following are referred
here the answer is
sage maker it provides every developer
and data scientist with the ability to
build train
and deploy machine learning models
quickly that's what sagemaker does
now for you to be familiar with you know
the the products i would
recommend you to you know simply go
through the
product description you know there's one
page available on amazon that explains
all the products a quick
neat and simple now that really helps
you to be very familiar with
you know what the product is all about
and what it is capable of you know is it
a db service is it a machine learning
service or is it a monitoring service is
it a developer service
stuff like that so get that information
get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face
such questions with great confidence so
the answer is amazon sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and data scientists the ability to build
the train and deploy
machine learning models quickly as
possible all right let's look at this
one
let's say that you are working for your
company's id
team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the aws resource based
on
the incoming application and network
traffic how
do you do it so what's the service
that's actually
helps us to adjust the capacity of the
aws resource based on
the incoming application let's look at
it amazon vpc
amazon iam amazon inspector amazon
elastic
load balancing amazon vpc is a
networking service amazon iam is an
username password authentication
amazon inspector is a service that
actually does
security audit in our environment and
amazon elastic load balancer is a
service that helps in
scalability that's in one way you know
indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and
monitoring it monitoring you know how
much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust
the uh environment that's running behind
it so the answer is going to be amazon
elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform
video game development engine that
supports pc
xbox playstation ios and android
platforms
allows developers to build and host
their games
on amazon's servers so we have
amazon game lift amazon green grass
amazon
lumber yard amazon sumerian let's
read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine
that supports pc xbox playstation ios
and android platforms allows developers
to build and host their games on amazon
servers the answer is amazon lumberyard
this lumberyard is an
free aaa gaming engine deeply integrated
with the
aws and twitch with full source this
lumbar yard provides a
growing set of tools that helps you
create and highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games
and vast compute and storage in the
cloud so it's that service they are
referring to let's look at this question
you are the project manager of your
company's cloud architect
team you are required to visualize
understand and manage your aws
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best
fit for this we have aws budgets we have
aws cost explorer we have amazon
work mail we have amazon connect and the
answer is going to be cost
explorer now cost explorer is an option
in
the amazon console that helps you
to visualize and understand and even
manage the aws cost over time who's
spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question
you are a chief cloud architect at your
company and
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust computer resources
to ensure maximum performance and
efficiency
of all scalable resources so we have a
cloud formation
as a service we have aws aurora as a
solution we have aws auto scaling and
amazon api gateway let's read the
question again you're the chief cloud
architect at your company how can you
automatically monitor
and adjust computer resources how can
you automatically monitor
and adjust computer resources to ensure
maximum performance and efficiency of
all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer
the answer is auto scaling right that's
a basic service and
solution architect course is it auto
scaling is the service that helps us to
easily adjust
monitor and ensure the maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources it does that by
automatically
scaling the environment to handle the
inputs let's look at this question as a
database administrator
you will use a service that is used to
set up and manage
databases such as mysql maya db and
postgres
sql which service are we referring to
amazon aurora amazon elastic cache aws
rds aws database migration service
amazon arora is
amazon's flavor of the rds service and
elastic cache
is is the caching service provided by
amazon they are not full-fledged
database and database migration service
just like the name says it helps to
migrate
the database from on-premises to the
cloud and
from one database flavor to another
database flavor
amazon rds is the service is the console
is the service is the umbrella service
that helps us to
set up manage databases like mysql money
db and
postgres sql it's amazon rds let's look
at this last question a part of your
marketing
work requires you to push messages to
onto google
facebook windows and apple through apis
or aws management console you will use
the following service
so the options are aws cloudtrail aws
config amazon chime aws simple
notification service
it says a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages
it's dealing with pushing messages to
google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console
you will use the following service it's
simple notification service
simple notification service is an
message pushing
a service and sqs is pulling similarly
sns
is pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages to
google facebook windows and apple
through api and it's going to be
a simple notification system or a simple
notification
service that's all i had uh 40
interesting
interview questions in part two and i'm
sure when you really understand
the background of the question and how
to answer the question
i'm sure you'll be able to crack the
interview and get the job
that you've been waiting for and we are
very glad
that we were able to provide such uh
thoughtful questions and answers we were
able to collect design
such thoughtful and answer questions and
provide it to you so you can prepare
well
and move forward in your career it's
samuel from simply learn thank you again
we'll meet you in another video as soon
as possible thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here